okay today I'm going to talk about the
topic in p1 about ultrasound and
infrasound now first of all we need to
know a little bit about sound waves I've
drawn two different sound waves here
so just to recap sound waves are
longitudinal longitudinal waves this
means that the direction of the
vibrations is the same direction that
the wave is traveling so they're in the
same direction now what we can see here
is we can actually see there's different
compressions in either wave so on this
top wave we can see we can measure the
wavelength which is the distance between
these different compressions so the
wavelength of the top one is quite short
whereas the wavelength for the bottom
one is quite long now this shorter the
wavelength the higher the frequency now
what ultrasound actually is is sound
that cannot be heard the frequency is
too high to be detected by the human ear
so it's any frequency above 20,000 Hertz
Hertz is just the units for frequency so
infrasound is like the opposite its
wavelength is very long meaning it has a
very low frequency it's anything which
is below 20 Hertz so again we can't hear
this sound because it's too low
frequency so we can actually use
infrasound and ultrasound for different
things you could use ultrasound for baby
scans and also for sonar in submarines
that we're going to look at in a minute
an infrasound is used by elephants to
communicate with other members of their
herd because basically this one could
travel over travel over long distances
and be diffracted around objects easily
so this one could be used by elephants
also meteor strikes and volcanic
eruptions produce infrasound which can
be used to detect them
really far away so that's the basics of
infrasound and ultrasound so we're going
to quickly now have a look how
ultrasound can be used in submarines as
sonar so what we have right here is
you'll see my beautiful joins underneath
the sea we can have a submarine
now this submarine can use sonar to try
and detect how far away different
objects are so this is how it works it
releases it emits our ultrasound which
travels down to the bottom of the seabed
the seafloor due to the high frequency a
lot of this sound is reflected back and
can then be detected by the submarine so
this here with my beautiful submarine
now we could actually use an equation
that we should have seen before to find
out exactly how far away this the sea
floor is by doing this equation speed
equals distance over time now we know or
rather we will be given this in the exam
we did not need to know to remember this
the speed of sound in sea water is 1520
meters per second so that's just how
fast this ultrasound is traveling
through the water so let's say let's say
in this particular instance it took ten
seconds for the ultrasound to hit the
hip the seafloor and reflect back up and
be detected by the submarine so this is
what we need to do because we're looking
to try and find the distance to the
seafloor
we cover up our distance so we now have
speed times time
so we're going to do 1520 multiplied by
10 which gives us
fifteen thousand two hundred meters now
this isn't our final answer because
what's that's told us is the distance
all the way from the submarine to the
seafloor and then all the way from the
seafloor back up to the submarine so all
that we need to do now is we just need
to divide that answer by two to find the
distance just to the seafloor so we're
doing fifteen thousand two hundred
meters because that was the distance
from here back up again divided by two
and the answer is seven thousand six
hundred meters so that is one very
important use of ultrasound thank you